حسنًا ، حتى لا نغوص هكذا
هنا في الغياب يمكننا الاستمرار
العلاقات وأكثر ، أنت تعرف الآن
فكرت في هذه المرة الأخيرة
مبادرة الاتصال
جاء من الرئيس بايدن
أريد أن أعرض على الرئيس بئر زورق
نواصل مناقشاتنا ولكن بشرط
أننا سنفعل ذلك بشكل مباشر
بث ما يسمى
عبر الإنترنت ولكن بدون أي تأخير ولكن بشكل مباشر
هنا في مناقشة مفتوحة مباشرة لي
تخيل أنه سيكون ممتعًا
لكل من شعوب روسيا والشعب
الولايات المتحدة وبالنسبة للكثيرين
دول أخرى ، أعني ما نحب
على أكبر الأكاذيب النووية الرخيصة
مسؤولية خاصة للاستراتيجية
الأمان على الكوكب هذا ما لن أفعله
تأجيله لعطلة نهاية الأسبوع
أريد أن أذهب إلى التايغا قليلاً
بقية وهكذا سيكون ممكنا أو غدا
أو نقول الاثنين من فضلك نحن
جاهزة في أي وقت مناسب للولايات المتحدة
وقت اليد أنا هنا الآن بعد ذلك
محادثتنا هناك مناسبة
تعليمات لوزارة الخارجية
حديثها
يعيش في الأساس
[موسيقى]